look at him anything about that look
normal to its reckon you chose to be an
international CIA's father satellite
boilers you are like Jason morning
George hi I'm Mike Zimmer from FX
guide.com for wired Dwayne the rock
Johnson and Kevin Hart star in Central
Intelligence as two old high school
friends who team up when one of them
joins the CIA the rock not only had to
be de-aged but changed significantly for
a guy who normally has four percent body
fat internet sensation Sione provided
the dance to Dwayne the face and wedded
digital the complex effects to pull this
off the young Rock's body you see in the
film is actually the body of vine star
Sione
both he and Johnson were scanned at ICTs
light stage using broad spectrum
lighting to get not only the some 40-odd
facts poses for the models but also to
get both of the two actors singing on
vogue
some of that reference included the rock
looking scared as visual effects
supervisor Martin hill from wetter told
us it's kind of hard to find any
reference footage of the action-hero
looking scared in his movies and while
we're to use face tracking animation
software to get an accurate performance
the team ended up mixing
ever-so-slightly between both of the
actors performances depending on the
shot building the younger Robbie Stone
where to head to meld the 44 year old
six-foot-five Johnson with the
20-something sione which is actually a
lot harder as Robbie Stone in the film
is younger than either of what you're
seeing on screen is CEO knees hair who
actually grew out for the film and his
body and a digital face based on the
rock actually their head shapes are
quite different in designing the young
stone it was important to still have the
character recognizable as Dwayne Johnson
the team took particular care around the
character's eyes to get that distinctive
chiseled eyebrow look and not to lose
the rock in Bob Stein look at him
anything about that look normal to Kevin
Hart was also actually D aged for the
sequence so they use the real Kevin as
their source for the young Calvin that
you see on the basketball court let's do
the Flip
that was so close Radio FX went on to
produce much of the rest of the visual
effects in the action sequences and the
rest of the film which is a lot of fun
don't forget subscribe for more behind
the scenes action
I might seem off for wide
Pressley remember saying that I was out
I know but they think you're the coolest
kid in high school this is like a total
transformation you used to be fat never
gonna get it